the wreckage of a downtown las vegas  fire has turned into a death  investigation as well  flames started what appeared to be a  vacant wedding chapel near las vegas  boulevard and oaky yesterday  fire officials now confirming a body was  found inside the wreckage  investigators are still working to  determine the cause  it was just too hot too dangerous for  anybody to go in that building last  night we had to wait till cool down  so just before lunch our fire  investigators  came on scene to start a preliminary  investigation to determine  the cause of the fire they wanted to see  where it started in the building so  they'll generally  start to do a walk around and when they  went inside  they saw a hand sticking out of the  rubble which indicated that there was a  deceased person inside the building  las vegas fire and rescue says metro  police now part of this investigation